there's experimental airships now that
they're looking to use similar to a
Zeppelin to move cargo to remote areas
of the world and that could be used for
anything from the food to construction
materials so they're looking at things
like that I know the government might
say they look into a lot of different
types of uses for airships I've heard
some larger airships that have been out
there in development for carrying heavy
cargo and trying to be able to stay up
in the air for long periods of time
those are the kinds of things that I see
on an airship like this being able to be
used for we started off with the
collaboration with Zeppelin in the early
1900s and now we're back again so it's
kind of project full circle for us all
the ships are called gz-20 sgz stands
for figure Zeppelin Zeppelin was leading
the build and for the manufacturing but
we were the technical support team
Zeppelin was the first company to really
have a true airship airline you look at
it and say wow that's really a part of
American history Roger started their
airship history in about 1911 with
building the first envelope for the
Akron vanaman these would have been
hydrogen filled the airships at the time
our current airships are all helium
filled this also shows a pretty good
look at the gondola here and how it's
attached with cables away from the car
because the hydrogen gas was flammable
so they wanted anything that had spark
to be away from the envelope 1925 was
our first blimpo's the pogrom this was
the first helium filled airship we're
involved in emergency response and
relief plans for several different
cities and did a lot of stuff with the
National Park Service's or the u.s.
wildlife folks and things like that up
and down the coastlines there could be
opportunities for maybe some scientific
missions maybe some ability to do
atmospheric studies in the new Goodyear
blimp is a whole new chapter in airshow
operations there are some versatile uses
of airships so I hope they do become
mainstream
you